Is there anything you can recommend to increase energy?
Okay, good question.
Anything you can recommend to increase energy?
Bear question.
But I would not be a good doctor
if I didn't ask a question of a question, right?
And the question to this question would be
asking the question line.
So why does a person, you've got to find out why a person has
a low energy?
So, yeah, do you want to increase energy?
What does the world tell you to do?
Well, you take that energy, drink,
go, you drink some caffeine or something like that.
Well, that's not treating the real cause
of the decrease energy.
So you've got to look at, okay,
what's causing my decrease energy?
So what could be causing decrease energy for anybody?
Whether you're a cancer patient or not.
Well, the first thing that you think of is an anemia.
So an anemia is when you have low red blood cell count
or low people go with both.
If that's the case,
that's definitely going to decrease your oxygen
carrying capacity of your red blood cells.
And that's going to decrease the energy
that you're getting to the brain.
That's where you're really going to feel the decrease energy.
So a person says, I don't have any energy.
They're not getting good oxygen carry capacity to the brain.
So treating the anemia,
so treating the cause of the decreasing energy
in this case, anemia is the most important thing.
So if the person has anemia with cancer,
do look at our blog post about treating anemia with cancer,
but definitely you're going to look at about adding some iron.
And if you're going to add some iron,
think about adding some artimisted as well.
If you're a bad iron,
you should always add artimisted and take them together.
Because the problem with anemia with cancer
is that cancer can gobble up iron.
And if you're going to,
if it's going to gobble up iron,
well, let's let artimisted ride with it.
So artimisted binds to iron
to have information on the blog post about that.
Artimisted binds to iron and artimisted can be a cancer killer.
So we're giving the option,
if the cancer is going to gobble up the iron,
it's going to gobble up the artimisted into
and we can actually kill the cancer via the artimisted.
So treating the anemia, treating the cause.
Let's say I have anemia due to something else.
Let's have anemia due to an infection
or let's have lack of energy due to an infection,
a chronic infection.
That's not an uncommon thing, a chronic infection.
How would you know that?
That would you know of your white blood cell cult
is about seven, maybe seven point five.
That's in the normal range.
If you look at a white blood cell test
you look at a CBC test.
Typically, both labs are going to say normal white blood cell
cult is 4.5 to 10.5 or maybe even 11.
But really, if you have a white blood cell cult
over seven point five, you do have a hidden infection.
That could be a cause of that of the decreased energy.
You could have just inflammation.
So chronic inflammation can be a cause of decreased
energy.
So that could be due to food sensitivities, food allergies.
I've had people with hidden food allergies in gluten.
And you know, it causes inflammation in the brain
and it causes just a decrease energy.
They get really super sleepy and can't figure out why I need
to be taken to drink coffee in the afternoon.
I feel like I need to take an app.
What's probably be it's because they're eating a food
that they have sensitivities too.
How would you find that out?
Run a Cyrex panel.
Typically a Cyrex array, a rate 10 gives you a test of 200 different foods
cooked in raw.
That would give you a good broad panel of,
do I have food sensitivities that I need to look at?
Remember, you know, your cheek swamp testing is not going to test
for antibodies to food.
So you know, you might have, you know,
I might have taken you off of, let's say, dairy or pork
or something like that.
That doesn't mean you have a food sensitivity to those things.
It means that's driving your cancer.
You could have food sensitivities, that is, i.e.
antibodies, two different foods or peptides in different foods
that can cause you all sorts of comorbidities.
So you might have cancer and you might have a decrease energy
totally caused from the cancer, but you could have cancer
and you could have a co-roredity of decreased energy
and it's caused from a totally different condition.
You know, that isn't even tied to the cancer.
Usually if you have anemia with cancer,
that's tied to the cancer.
But you could have a chronic infection that's not tied to the cancer.
You could have inflammation due to food sensitivities
or food antibodies that's not tied to the cancer.
You could have another totally different disorder
and most commonly would be an autoimmune disorder.
So looking at that might be a thing.
So looking if you have an autoimmune condition,
would be, and that would be, you know,
it should be a contact call with baby
because we need to talk about that.
But how you test for that is you would do a Cyrox array
five, if you thought it was an autoantibodies
to peripheral tissues or a seven X,
if you thought it was antibodies to neural tissue.
So that's, Cyrox labs is the best labs to look for antibodies.
So you can go through that.
So no, there isn't, you know, let's say it's none of these
and let's say, you know, a common cause for a decrease,
just a mild decrease energy can be an adrenal fatigue.
You're getting just, you know, just fatigue
from all the weirdness of treating your,
treating your cancer and treating your, you know, whatever.
You just have the adrenal fatigue and some low energy
from just a hormone suppression,
common with people that are dealing with chronic disease
of all kinds.
And then you'd think of what would you do for that?
You'd think of adaptogens.
So adaptogens are different nutrients
that can just help bring up the aderitals,
can calm down a hyperadrenal state,
can just kind of balance your hormones
and can really help you with anxiety and with stress issues,
chronic stress can certainly cause adrenal fatigue
and then you end up with a decrease energy.
So that, obviously, this is super common with anybody
dealing with cancer or any other disease long term
and this can be addressed with just adaptogens.
The beauty of adaptogenic herbs is that you can't take too many
of them, you know, you just can't.
And it just helps bring balance.
So if your aderitals are fatigued, it can help bring that up.
And if your aderitals are in overdrive
because you're just in a stress state,
it can help bring that down.
Hence, adapting you to the environment,
that's where it can stay.
So those are some things that you think of.